hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today they're
gonna be going over the czech Benoni one
of the more common ways that you'll see
the benoni played it starts out with a
d4 and that f6 c4 and then after c5
white pushes forward with d5 here and
there's three main lines that you'll see
black play here the first one is gonna
be the Bangko game it which is how I
like to play and that is b5 then you
have the modern Benoni which is e six
and then you have the check my own E
which we're gonna be covering today and
that is e five now it is more sound than
the other openings both the modern and
the Banco gambit very aggressive lines
this is not that at all it tends to be a
very closed game so you'll see some
positions later on we're looking for
some long middle and endgame so if
you're one of those players that you
like those very long games where it's
not a lot of material is trading off
early on this definitely could be the
defense for you we're gonna be looking
at a few variations one is going to be
if they decide to take here so on
passant if you're not familiar with this
move the first time a player plays their
pawn up two squares if there's another
pawn right next to it they have one move
in one move only to capture like this so
this is a legal move for white so we'll
be going over that the other one is if
they play e4 which looks like it's
undefended so that I can easily take it
it's not so we're gonna look at what
that looks like then we're also going to
be looking at both the Knights coming
here to f3 and then the main line which
is what most players are gonna run into
and that is Knight to c3 hopefully you
guys enjoy the video so the first line
is going to be on pissant with white
taking here on e6 you're really not
gonna see it too often but I just want
to make sure everyone is prepared if you
do come across this you're gonna
recapture with your F pawn generally in
chess you want to capture towards the
center of the board always trying to
control the center there are a few cases
where you may not want to we'll do
another video on when you may not want
to capture towards the center but in
this case you absolutely do
want to capture towards the center of
the board but then where do they
actually continue from here maybe Knight
to f3 getting a minor piece developed
into the center of the board
black pretty much every move is going to
be pushing here with a d5 has both the
pond the Queen and the Knights all
protecting the square right here so
depending on where they go you know if
they capture here black recaptures black
has center control right here can get
both of his bishops involved into the
game his night here on c6 very easy if
he doesn't capture here may want to get
his not involved into the game but then
black pushes forward here to d4 this is
a pretty awkward setup now the white
knight has to move here and then
eventually you could get the Queen here
to a5 just not really the setup that
White's looking for so again really not
gonna see white taking that pawn early
on with on passant I just want to let
people know what you could see if it did
happen in the game now the next
variation you could see is efore because
it looks like that black can just take
here on e4 and while it's not
necessarily a trap you're not gonna get
that free pawn but I still think you
need to take it if you don't take it
you're not gonna have nearly as good a
setup as you probably think you would so
I'd recommend just go ahead and taking
this on e4 but be prepared for the move
Queen to e2 now if they don't play Queen
e2 then they truly did just give up this
pawn here on e4 but this is going to get
the material back because once this
Knight moves this Knights under attack
here this pawn here on e5 is going to
fall now then I could come back right
away it could come to f6 or d6 I prefer
d6
but it could also hold on to this
material for at least a short amount of
time and that move would be at 5 and the
reason I like this is because it forces
White's hand a little bit if we just
bring our knight back here to d6 then
they're gonna play Queen takes on e5 we
play Queen e7 they could exchange if
they want to but they still have a
pretty good setup right here if instead
we play pawn to f5 we essentially are
forcing them to play something like f3
and this is now forcing the
to move away which they will get that
material back so after Knight to d6 yes
they can come down take here on e5 and
we can play Queen to e7
but the difference now is this pawn on
f3 much weaker setup for white at both
weekends the King side the board and
also weekends the square the natural
progression for where this Knight would
want to come to on f3 so this is
definitely what I prefer and this is
pinning down the Queen so white has some
options you're usually not just going to
take because now black can just
recapture castle on the King side of the
board has a lot more minor pieces
developed in the game so you could see
something like f4 that says yeah if you
want to capture my Queen I'll recapture
this is a great setup for White has
center control attacking the knight here
now the knight is forced to move can't
come here to c4 because that is defended
by the bishop here on f1 so blacks
probably not gonna recapture what I
recommend in this position is Knight to
e4 the main reason is it looked like the
Knights was actually defending the
square here on f5 and as soon as it
comes up to e4 this looks like an
outpost but it's also leaving this pawn
here on f5 undefended but it actually is
defended because after the Queen takes
if it takes I mean that would be a huge
mistake
you could play Knight to g3 this is a
discovered attack on the King and it's
also attacking the Queen here on f5 the
Queen is going to fall why it's gonna
fall black is definitely going to win
the game so yes
early on I would recommend taking with
your nights here on e4 but just
recognize that you're not gonna be able
to hold on to that pond as soon as they
play Queen to e2
the next version that you could see is
Knight to f3 and you have two options
here if you're playing the Czech benoni
generally you are playing a longer game
you're looking for a clock center of the
board and so you're probably gonna be
playing something like the six because
this is what you do in the Czech
Pannonian we'll go over that and the
main line here in a second so after
Knight to c3 play Bishop to e7
pawn to e4 you castle on the kingside
and this is kind of the main setup that
you're used to seeing if you're playing
the Czech benoni but I recommend just
because I like to take aggressive lines
in most openings that I play here
instead of these six I recommend pushing
forward with efore and this is just
common practice to start pushing your
pawns forward up the board hey they have
a pun on the fifth rank is white pushing
up so you have a pawn on the fourth rank
is black forcing the Knights move now
that the knight doesn't have a lot of
great options they're usually gonna come
back to d2 and this is where it gets a
little tricky and you definitely need to
play this quite a few times to recognize
that this is not necessarily a bad move
but if on the face of it you you look at
and say I don't know if I like that
position then just go ahead and play the
d6 because you are going to give up
material in this line and that is
playing III and they may look at this
and just recapture and yes that that is
absolutely what we are recommending here
because then blacks gonna continue with
their game plan but look at the game
board and how white continues yes
they're up upon a material but both of
these pawns right here are blocking the
light squared bishop they don't have
good kingside safety because their F
pawns gone it's gonna take some time
before they could even develop enough to
get to kingside safety if they want to
castle on the King side they can't move
this pawn here so they're gonna be
pushing maybe g3 but now it looks really
awkward if they castle on the King side
they're not gonna be cancelling on the
Queen side any time soon it's gonna be
difficult to hold on to both of these
pawns later on Black has a lot of
opportunity to start to attack these
pawns so black gave up a little material
right away for a much stronger position
right away and then later on much a
stronger attacking line so Bishop to g7
potentially Bishop to G to d6 opening up
for the light square bishop you get
involved into the game once you start
playing this more I think you'll
recognize that black has a lot of good
options but if we come back and say yeah
I just don't want to give up that pawn
then you probably don't want to be
playing for instead just go ahead and
play that d6
and that brings us to
the main line which is what you're gonna
see most of the time and that is Knight
to c3 you're gonna respond with d6 the
general I'm gonna respond with E 4 and
then Bishop to e7 and then Bishop to d3
and a lot of players when they think
about the Czech bodoni this is the
specific setup that they are looking at
there's a lot of things to keep in mind
from both sides of the board black has a
pretty cramped position here White's
really far up the board here you can see
both these pawns in the center are equal
here but why it is much farther up the
board than black yeah this pawn here on
d6 is cramping a lot of the squares that
black can go the Starks Square bishops
not going anywhere for a while the light
square bishop can get outside that the
pawn chain and start doing some stuff
but black is really going to be looking
at some point to start pushing up with
these pawns on the flanks but at the
same time that blacks looking to that
white can also be looking to attack on
the flanks as well here on the F file
and the B file now if both sides aren't
looking to do that they may also start
to attack with their their other
material and see how they can maneuver a
different way so black may be looking to
bring his knight to a6 and then
eventually to c7 and then at some point
attacking here on b5 or if he wants to
push his pawn forward he can do that as
well sometimes if we see the knight
coming here to a6 you could see white
start to attack on the Queen side the
board and you start to have a race
sometimes you'll even see that black
will pushes pawn up here to a7 and then
white will respond with a 4 just wants
to stop the threat of the pond coming up
here to b5 and then all of a sudden you
have this critical square here on b4
that's a great outpost that black can
get to and it's then very difficult for
white to actually attack this square
right here so there's a lot of stuff
going on and part of the way that I like
to approach this from black is a waiting
game and not committing to one specific
variation and kind of waiting to see
what your opponent's going to do
and so the first move that I like to
play from here is just castling on the
kingside some players want a man who
could commit they'll play tonight here
to e6 but I like to go and castle on the
kingside and to give you an example of
why that would be let's say that white
immediately starts to attack on the
kingside and plays f4 ok well black
captures here the Bishop recaptures and
then black decides yeah I want to go
ahead and get my knight here to d7 the
main reason is you want to bring your
knight here to e5 this is a great
outpost you can start to attack this
lights for a bishop right here it's very
difficult for white to really do much
and then let's say they played Knight to
f3 then you could even play Knight to g4
and then both of your Knights are both
aimed at the square here on e5 and you
can easily control that now that's very
different than if you were to come back
a few moves and if they play instead of
cancelling on the King side if you play
Knights a6 now all of a sudden they play
f4 you take they recapture and you kind
of sit here and wonder ok well I've
castle on the King side that's the same
but then they play Knight to f3 and
they've already started to attack the
King side of the board maybe too late to
start to attack on the Queen side so I
feel like castling a little earlier even
though it's one move gives you more
options as far as how you want to
continue now let's say they don't play
f4 cuz that could be pretty aggressive
early on instead after Bishop to d3
castle on the King side maybe they
played Knight to f3 at this point they
have an attacked on the King said maybe
at this point you want to play Knight to
a6 and start to attack on the Queen side
so you definitely have some options if
they play something Bishop to g4 v just
know this is a huge mistake because you
can just take material here on d5 this
is a free pawn if they take your Bishop
you're going to recapture with your
knight here you're up a pawn if they say
yeah I'll just go ahead and take your
take your Knights ok will you take their
Bishop and you're up a pawn here so
that's gonna be a mistake sometimes
players don't recognize that they can't
just pin down your knight to bishops
when they have some pawns in the center
of the board it doesn't always work like
they want to especially in the Czech
bodoni when they
have this pawn here on d5 so keep that
in mind if they try something else
you know castle on the kingside and then
a three you know from here you have a
lot of different options I would say
rook here to e8 you don't have to commit
to anything right away you don't know
cuz they could play a three and then
start to push forward here on f4 so I
would continue normal game plan
get your rooks center of the board and
get your light square bishop board if
you want to eventually you can start to
push it on the Queen side so you
definitely have some options but really
black needs to make sure that you're
attacking on the wings at some point you
don't want to have such a cramped
position that you don't have any
fighting chance you don't want to play
this just for a drawl you have some
strong attacks but you are going to have
to attack on either the Kings side or
the Queen side at some point but you can
tell from these positions no material
has come off the board it's going to be
a much longer middle and end game so if
you like these positions if you're
looking this and you say I could
definitely maneuver around here this is
my type of game then the check benoni
could definitely be for you thanks so
much for watching the video if you liked
the video if you wouldn't mind please
click on the like button definitely
helps the channel if you haven't already
subscribed please subscribe if you have
other videos you'd like me to make you
can always leave a comment or the best
way to contact me is through email the
chess website at gmail.com or there is a
chat functionality on to the website you
can always chat me I try to respond as
often as I can
thanks again for watching the video I'll
see you guys in the next one
you